[Música]
la crisis sanitaria empeora en américa
latina' brasil registró este martes su
peor cifra de fallecimientos con casi
2.000 muertes y un repunte en las
hospitalizaciones y paraguay y está en
alerta roja por más de 2.100 nuevos
contagios su mayor pico desde el inicio
de la pandemia y con protestas contra el
manejo de la emergencia
en minneápolis eeuu avanza la selección
de miembros del jurado para el juicio
contra dirección juana el ex policía que
ahogó hasta la muerte al afroamericano
george roy de el año pasado se espera
que la elección de los 12 jurados tome
tres semanas y que el juicio se abra el
29 de marzo
y a 10 años del desastre en la central
nuclear de fukushima la onu publicó un
nuevo estudio que señala que los efectos
en la salud debido a la radioactividad
no son demostrables y asegura que la
subida de casos de cáncer de tiroides
entre los jóvenes se debe a otros
factores el gobierno nipón no sigue
investigando sus efectos tenemos
análisis
regresamos con ustedes para actualizar
la información más importante de américa
latina y del mundo iniciamos el
informativo con kobe 19 en américa del
sur brasil y vive el peor momento de la
pandemia tras registrar un nuevo récord
de diario de muertes con 1972 víctimas y
advierte del grave repunte en las
hospitalizaciones
mientras tanto paraguay decretó la
alerta roja sanitaria al registrar en
una sola jornada el mayor número de
nuevos positivos especialistas en salud
de este país se señalan que la variante
brasileña estaría circulando en su
territorio por esa misma razón argentina
considera aplicar restricciones
fronterizas ante la variante
paraguay entra en alerta roja sanitaria
el gobierno decidió imponer la medida
luego de que el martes se registrará la
cifra más alta de contagios de toda la
pandemia con 2 mil 125 casos en un solo
día
paraguay se encuentra en estos momentos
en el nivel de alerta roja sanitaria
debido al aumento sostenido y récord de
contagios de koi 19 registrados en los
últimos días por lo que se ruega
encarecidamente a la población tener
conciencia y evitar situaciones que
puedan poner en riesgo la salud
individual y colectiva
y es que las autoridades sanitarias
señalan que las multitudinarias
protestas en contra del gobierno pueden
incrementar los contagios las
manifestaciones llevan cinco días
consecutivos impulsaron la salida de
cuatro ministros
en brasil la pandemia tampoco da tregua
el martes fue el día con más muertos por
coronavirus al contabilizar 1972
fallecimientos en 24 horas además la
agencia oficial fiocruz especializada en
tecnología de la salud también advirtió
un grave repunte de las
hospitalizaciones ante la situación
extremadamente crítica de las tasas de
ocupación de las camas de uci cobit que
indican sobrecarga e incluso colapso de
los sistemas de salud
los investigadores refuerzan el boletín
la necesidad de ampliar y fortalecer las
medidas no farmacológicas que involucran
la distancia física y social uso de
mascarillas e higiene de manos
en el país vecino argentina la principal
preocupación es por cuenta de la
variante brasileña el ministro de salud
de la provincia de buenos aires dijo que
el consejo nacional de salud discutirá
la posibilidad de restringir más la
frontera con brasil de aplicarse las
medidas podrían comenzar a partir del 12
de marzo
mientras tanto chile se convirtió en el
país que más rápidamente vacuna a sus
habitantes our world data de la
universidad de oxford señala que en
promedio el país austral está aplicando
108 dosis diarias de por cada 100
habitantes la información corresponde a
los últimos 7 días el ministro de salud
enrique parís habló de los datos y
recordó que ya fueron inoculados casi 5
millones de ciudadanos desde diciembre
hasta ahora israel era el país que venía
liderando la inoculación de dosis con
base en el promedio de los últimos siete
días en el último recuento quedó en 103
dosis por cada 100 personas
la vacunación en los territorios
palestinos o no avanza mientras israel
ya ha inmunizado a cerca de un 40 por
ciento de su población en cisjordania y
la franja de gaza vive en una nueva
oleada de kobe 19 y atraviesan un grave
colapso hospitalario muchos palestinos
critican que sus vecinos e israelíes que
en un momento llegaron hasta a bloquear
el envío de fármacos a los territorios
palestinos no donen más vacunas para
acelerar la campaña de inoculación más
romeros tiene los detalles
en israel abren los restaurantes y los
bares más de la mitad de su población ha
recibido al menos una inyección de la
vacuna contra el cob y 19 en una de las
campañas de inmunización más rápidas del
planeta
pero a la vez en los vecinos territorios
palestinos regresaron las cuarentenas
para tratar de frenar una nueva ola de
contagios que tienen los hospitales
colapsados
actualmente la pandemia se ha extendido
mucho en cisjordania la mayoría de
instituciones médicas y hospitales
con haití al día nada nuestro mayor
problema es que tenemos 28 camas y todas
están llenas entre cisjordania y la
franja de gaza sólo se han recibido 34
mil 700 dosis de vacunas para una
población de 52 millones
los palestinos acusan primero a la
propia autoridad palestina por
distribuir de manera desigual las
vacunas y segundo a israel por no
responsabilizarse de estos territorios
que tienen una autonomía limitada y
siguen ocupados
el gobierno israelí les donó unos pocos
miles de vacunas y el lunes extendió su
campaña de inmunización a los palestinos
que se trasladan a israel para trabajar
muchos en empleos precarios como la
construcción de peces en operation
estamos en una operación para vacunar a
todos los trabajadores palestinos que
trabajan en israel y espero que todos
vengan lo antes posible la
administración civil y el ministerio de
salud están haciendo un gran esfuerzo
para que esta operación tenga éxito y
sin embargo son sólo 120.000
aproximadamente los palestinos que
trabajan en israel todavía faltan 5
millones más
honduras se convirtió en un narcoestado
eso fue lo que dijeron fiscales
estadounidenses en la ciudad de nueva
york en el marco del juicio contra el
presunto traficante de drogas de
giovanni fuentes ramírez señalaron la
complicidad del gobierno y de las
fuerzas armadas para mover grandes
cantidades de cocaína a eeuu uno de los
colaboradores habría sido el propio
presidente juan orlando hernández además
de otros políticos del país
y en minneápolis eeuu continúa la
selección de miembros del jurado para el
juicio contra derek suman el ex oficial
de policía que asfixió con la rodilla a
georges floyd durante un arresto que
acabó con su vida el año pasado floyd el
ciudadano afro de 46 años suplico por su
vida el hecho quedó registrado en un
video aficionado que se convirtió en una
prueba de la brutalidad policial y que
desembocó en el proceso para el cual a
ella fueron elegidos 3 de los 12
miembros del jurado hay tres semanas de
plazo para las elecciones que será
cuidadosa por señalamientos de racismo
en el sistema judicial jouan fue
despedido de la policía y liberado de la
cárcel en octubre pasado con una fianza
de un millón de dólares este es un caso
histórico estoy bastante segura de que
terminaremos con un jurado justo e
imparcial y tengo que creer eso de todos
modos porque para obtener el resultado
que queremos tenemos que creer que las
personas adecuadas están ahí pasaron
diez años desde la catástrofe de la
central nuclear de fukushima en japón es
destruida parcialmente por un tsunami
tras un fuerte terremoto de magnitud 9 y
aún se siguen investigando los efectos
de la
radiación el gobierno nipón señaló que
continúan las indagaciones en la salud
de los habitantes por su parte de la onu
emitió un nuevo informe en el que
reitera hallazgos del 2014 según los
cuales el aumento de cáncer de tiroides
en jóvenes no puede atribuirse a la
contaminación radioactiva vamos a ir al
análisis y nos acompaña para ello o
florentino rodado catedrático de la
universidad complutense de madrid y
autor del libro la soledad del país
vulnerable sobre la historia reciente de
japón señor florentino bienvenido y
usted ha examinado la sociedad japonesa
con sus golpes y sus dificultades pero
también con su capacidad de resiliencia
tras los hechos dolorosos como el
desastre de la planta de fukushima diez
años después está superado este dolor la
gente aún no quiere volver a la región
pese a los reportes de que la
radiactividad es mucho menor
efectivamente desgraciadamente hay que
decir que fukushima no es historia
es una pena decirlo pero si es verdad
entonces si se han conseguido algunas
cosas efectivamente se abrieron y además
escuelas muy bien dotadas para que la
gente volviera se han abierto casas se
han abierto pueblos etcétera y
efectivamente hay algunas gentes que han
vuelto no pero hay que decir que todavía
faltan muchísimas cosas por hacer por
ejemplo a ver dónde se van a poner los
restos de la radiación
hay que decidir eso precisamente donde
vuelve la gente hay algunas cosas algún
empezado a vaciar algo del elemento de
la energía que quedaba allí en fukushima
de los de los restos que había pero
fíjense me parece que estaba leyendo el
2032 cuando se piensa que se podría
vaciar todo lo todo lo restante etc
y siguen varios pueblos además de que
todavía son inhabitables y este desastre
profesor se conjuga con otro fenómeno
preocupante y es el envejecimiento de la
población más que en cualquier otra
parte de japón
allí disminuye la densidad poblacional y
tiene la gente razón en sentirse aún hoy
en peligro por la radioactividad de pese
a informes como el que vimos de la onu
que dice que cáncer de tiroides en los
niños no aumentó por el accidente de la
planta
justo desde luego fíjense que desde el
principio la información que se dio en
japón fue muy carente de verdad se les
dijeron cosas precisamente para que
estuvieran demasiado tranquilos y la
cosa estuve normal en en este caso por
ejemplo la diferencia fue que se pudo
ver en televisoras si uno de los retos
es eso ahí por lo menos se pudo ver
claramente hay 90 pero si efectivamente
el problema de la población de japón es
muy grave
fíjense que hace cinco años fue me
parecen 126 millones habitantes
actualmente está bajando fíjense qué
las cifras más o menos son me parece 30
30 mil personas qué
digamos que mueren más de los que de los
que nacen entonces la situación en japón
está muy grave y precisamente el
problema es eso que solamente la zona de
tokio es la única que tiene aumento de
educación todo el resto del país
ha bajado subió un poquito la zona de
casa y la zona de kioto kobe y osaka
precisamente por gente venida de la zona
de tohoku no don del accidente pero
efectivamente ahí hay un problema muy
granja con es el exceso de nazis perdón
el exceso de 70 sur entonces aquí
precisamente es uno de los problemas
pero fíjense que es un problema para
todo el mundo es decir japón lo está
experimentando antes porque japón apenas
ha tenido población inmigrante
pero esto es una cosa que no se está
moviendo todo no le digo el caso de
españa también porque el caso de japón
fue en 2016 fue el primer año en el que
tuvieron menos de un millón de asia vale
bien bueno en españa fue lo mismo que me
parece que hubo menos de dos mil
doscientos mil nacimientos en el año
2000 2010 pero claro en españa había
ocurrido 20 años antes en el año 1999 me
equivoco si no me equivoco pero lo que
pasa es que españa con la emigración
volvió a aumentar el número de el número
de nacimientos que ha ocurrido por
objetos inmigrante pues está pues en un
principio procrear mal pero luego dejan
de prosperar y vuelven y se hacen
españoles como los demás entonces de
nuevo ahora la población española aún en
todos nadie los aumentaron pero han
vuelto a declinar por debajo de los 200
mil gracias eso bien entonces fíjense
osa las situaciones muy similares ocurre
en todo el mundo
pero que aún en japón no todavía no se
logra superar muchísimas gracias son por
sus consideraciones y continuamos con
más noticias aumenta la crisis política
en armenia en el cáucaso hoy el primer
ministro niccoló jinyan anunció que
considera legalmente destituido de su
cargo al jefe del estado mayor de las
fuerzas armadas única gasparian mientras
que los militares y el mismo gasparian
afirman que el proceso es
inconstitucional e insisten en que la
única vía para solucionar la crisis es
la dimisión del primer ministro y
elecciones anticipadas pero que llevó a
esta crisis y porque el descontento con
la gestión de patxi nyan nuestro
corresponsal en ereván armenia beatriz
hasta el 'ariana' nos amplia
a partir del fin de la guerra de nagorno
van a pagarme que se encuentra sumida en
una profunda crisis política marcada por
las movilizaciones de la oposición y los
ciudadanos descontentos que exigen la
renuncia del primer ministro o nicole
para sinha y lo acusan de poner en
riesgo la seguridad nacional y la
integridad territorial de su país hoy el
gobierno anunció la destitución del jefe
de estado mayor de las fuerzas armadas
únicas varian manifestando que debido a
que el presidente no firmó en el tiempo
establecido
el proyecto sobre su despido presentado
por el primer ministro ni tampoco lo
presentó ante el tribunal constitucional
legalmente o nicas variant debe dejar de
ejercer sus funciones en las fuerzas
armadas a partir de hoy por su parte
gaspar y ante emitió un comunicado en el
cual reafirmó que esta medida no es
constitucional y también recurrió a el
tribunal administrativo a los fines de
garantizar
la supremacía de la ley el resto de las
autoridades militares apoyaron este
mensaje del jefe de estado mayor de las
fuerzas armadas aunque el gobierno ya
nombró a su sucesor art acta de tian
para que ocupe este cargo mientras tanto
continúan las movilizaciones por parte
de la oposición encabezadas por el
movimiento de salvación de la patria en
la sede de la asamblea nacional de
yereván
esto es france24
[Música]